welcome
Ideas compete for a place in your mind: pictures of cats, news, beliefs, forms,
Funny photos, educational videos, educational videos and limited space of thought.
An idea without a mind thinks it, you die.
Now we are dealing with ideas as if they are alive. Such as microbes.
It may seem strange, but be patient with me.
Take jokes, for example. Bacteria germs live in your mind - and when you say humor
For another mind, help it spread.
Such as the flu that spreads if you completely thirst. The bacteria enter
To the body through the mouth or in our example words across the ear. But it is an infection
in both cases.
Entering the social networking pages, then, is exposing yourself to the insults of all people's minds. Each
A leaf containing an intellectual germ trying to get into your mind - even if you do not have to stay forever
It is at least a period of time that will make you press the button to participate in the idea
For all the minds you know.
In this context, the image of a funny cat with the perfect suspension will be a superhero flu.
Just as germs exploit the weak points of your immune system, you use intellectual germs
Weaknesses in your mind. More clearly: emotions.
When they enter, intellectual germs play with emotion to spread more
-- Much more. Except grief, the sad intellectual germs do not spread much.
Very good and this is why I see antibacterial spores like biological weapons
Arm them with titles such as: "7 things will stun you" or "dangerous secret
Behind ... this thing "
But anger is the lethal weapon of intellectual germs. Anger infiltrates behind your immune system,
And force you to spread the germ.
Your awareness of the weaknesses of your mind is very important to clean your mind - as your science
How to wash your hands. Because even without deliberate, or germ
An intellectual on the Internet can, alone, infect many minds while spreading. If we talked about
Cause, let's forget the anger for a moment and go back to the image of the cat.
Each image taken is a germ of thought, and most of them die dead as fast as billions
Images for cats (or children) that are placed online but do not spread. But it is a small picture
Funny screenshots can grow a lot, because it's our transatlantic journeys
The best thing that can happen to germs, the Internet is the best thing that can happen
Of intellectual germs.
The image of the cat is an intellectual germ, when riding it jumps to other minds. And
Those minds may publish them, and here's the key point, sometimes changing them - in Photoshop here
Edit the comment there.
Most of the modifications are very bad, but some make the intellectual germ more funny, helping the minds
To publish more. Leading to more changes and a greater likelihood of fame. And so slowly
Cat's image is capable of achieving mastery over minds. For at least a few hours.
The Internet, with its unique ability to propagate and indiscriminate change of intellectual germs
It must make them stronger.
With jokes, this is good - but it is not always good with spores of anger. No.
The germs of anger, the more they spread the more they go through the same stages of change and distortion
To become more provocative. They have a better chance of spreading than they are more accurate
But be dull.
But as the plague, the germs of intellect can burn quickly. See
Any program that makes Internet publications, and will see a full-blown microbial life cycle.
But some intellectual germs have found a way to avoid this extinction. I have to warn you that it is Ali
Any germ that lives in your mind, the next part may
Sounds scary. Please take this into account, we are talking about what makes some
Intellectual germs, especially angry ones, are successful. We do not talk about whether they are good or bad.
The same deep .. Calm.
Intellectual germs are able to flare up because once everyone agrees, it is difficult to keep talking, and thus
Think about them.
But if there is an opposing intellectual germ, a controversy, in which case thinking can not stop. Controversy
You do not have to be full of anger, but again, anger helps! The more controversy becomes apparent
The greater the number of participants in the debate, the more participants in the debate, the more controversial the debate, which helps any group
One of the most quiet internet sites turns into a double rage storm
In less than a second!
Wait a moment! These intellectual germs do not wrestle! They suffer! In collaboration
They have access to more minds and stick to their ideas more than the work of each of them individually. When germs are intellectual
On opposite sides of a controversy, this makes them co-existent.
One of the means used by "living spores of anger" is either you are with us or you are against us!
If you feel any germ on your head, just push it back. This video
This is not really why. We are only talking about this medium, which makes it difficult for neutral minds
To resist, being hostile also helps to grow their partner.
This explains why the number of enemies increases as the number of allies grows in a debate. Because he
Although the participants in the debate think they are in a fierce war
But from the perspective of germs, there is a side of roses, and the other side a flock of butterflies.
Of course the more roses, the more butterflies, the more butterflies,
The more roses thrive the more
If I am there is a strong argument divides the people into two halves, and lasts forever until that
Neutralists find it difficult to avoid this division, you are definitely looking at a husband now
Of the spores of anger that have finally reached a stable environment
And now the last bleak idea.
Those that will reveal your secrets, - actually are not just a bleak idea.
When the opposing groups grow up, they really do not argue with each other, they actually argue
With themselves for their anger around the other group. In fact we can record quarrels
That occur online to see this practically. Each group in its own part becomes isolated from the rest of the Internet,
They share their thoughts about the other group!
We can now see where this will happen to us, right ?!
Each group becomes a breeding ground for "intellectual germs" from the other group - as we have said before
The most "angry" - and not necessarily the right - will spread faster. Each group will
To build an angry "picture" of the other group to talk about it all the time
In the same way that you are now aware, this "picture" will always remain
Exciting.
All of the above was not to say that there is no purpose of argument. (We talked about this in a previous video).
Or to say that "Internet" is not surprising, or that it is useless to try to change
Human Views. Intellectual germs come and go.
But it is useful to be aware of how thought can use our feelings of diffusion
And how the faster the spread of the idea the greater the chance to become * better *
In diffusion through different changes. Sometimes this is excellent, but in some others,
It becomes terrible.
But if you want to maintain a healthy mind, you should be careful of the ideas that are
Pass through different minds to attack you in your weaknesses.
It's your mind - keep it healthy!
This video intellectual germ turn, deliberately prepared
To spread the idea of ​​germs on the germs of intellectual - to reveal our secrets - in the words of some.
But I tried as much as possible not to make this video attack your mind through emotions,
So I need your help to spread. Please be a good germist and press the share button
To snooze this video on your friends. And your colleagues at work. Your family. Put them all in the infection.
You've shared the video, have not you? If you are still here, you have been severely infected.
The only other thing is to click here to share the e-mail, which will show you
For more intellectual germs like this video.